hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in his work fear and trembling sir and
Kierkegaard introduces a certain
character or if you want to be a little
bit more exact a human type a
possibility as he says for for all of us
if we so choose to embrace and endorse
that type he calls it the night of
infinite resignation and it's a very
good thing to be such a night
the word night and the associations with
chivalry should not mislead us into
thinking that he's only talking about
men this is equally possible for women
as some of the examples that he will use
show us but there is an idea about
recognizing some sort of motivational
value that that centers one's life that
you could even express in a vow so the
the courtly or chivalric notion here is
definitely on point I should also point
out that there is another type of night
a yet higher sort that he will compare
and contrast the night of infinite
resignation against and that is the
night of faith who will talk about
elsewhere now most people are neither of
these nights most people are actually
lost in what Kierkegaard calls the
aesthetic he doesn't talk about that
quite so much in this work but
Kierkegaard has this notion of three
basic stages or perspectives or outlooks
on life there's the aesthetic where we
are concerned with the finite
particulars that were engaged in we are
spreading ourselves out over many
different things there is no single
concentration giving our life a center
and value we absorb things over and over
again and we may weigh them against each
other but really any of them are
exchangeable for for any others the
ethical
is different when we move from the
aesthetic into the ethical we recognize
that there are what we might call
definite and fixed hierarchies of goods
there are prioritizations that we want
to make or at least recognize if we fail
to see them through in actual practice
and within the ethical there can be a
number of different let's call them
smaller stages but there is some
recognition at each of those stages that
there's some value that trumps
everything else and the night of
infinite resignation is somebody who
moves within the ethical that doesn't
mean that the aesthetic doesn't exist
for them but the ethical centers and
Orient's everything Kierkegaard has a
wonderful line here that we're going to
come back to when we talk about the leap
into the infinite he talks about most
people living completely absorbed in
worldly joys and sorrows he calls them
Benchwarmers who do not take part in the
dance he tells us that the nights of
infinity are ballet dancers and have
elevation they leap up into the infinite
and we'll talk about precisely what that
means towards the end of this little
discussion first however let's talk
about this other aspect Kierkegaard
tells us that the night of infinite
resignation in his own words will have
the power to concentrate the as he says
the whole substance of his life and the
meaning of actuality into one single
desire notice those two things the
meaning of his or her life what it is
that they choose to make their life be
about in the whole of actuality going
beyond merely themselves and thinking
about what gives the world its value
what makes things important this is
something distinctively human that we
can do we are meaning producing
creatures
and this is a very important aspect of
how in fact we we do behave so
concentrating one's life and meaning
into one desire another way of putting
this could be one value one thing that
we see as inherently valuable that we
would not exchange for something else or
sacrifice to other things
we might even talk about it as one love
and Kierkegaard will use one's love as
an example of this but we could also
think more broadly in terms of whatever
it is that occupies our heart and has
its call upon us that we recognize and
choose to heed he tells us as well that
the night of Infinite resignation will
resist very important temptation a
temptation to make themselves either to
forget who they are now why might they
do this well the night of infinite
resignation not only recognizes some
value as intrinsically higher than the
others but has to resign him or herself
precisely because that value cannot in
this finite world be realized in the way
that they would like to see it happen so
one way of dealing with that is to
forget who you are and become somebody
different and no longer be motivated in
that way people who choose to try to
lose their themselves in drugs or
alcohol or some other addictive thing
you know lose themselves an exercise
lose themselves in dieting lose
themselves in work in making money in
having one affair after another after
another they're not going to be the
knight of infinite resignation and
they're precluding that possibility for
themselves Kierkegaard says will this
person forget it all no Annie
though that might be a sort of
concentration why he says the night does
not contradict himself and it's a
contradiction to forget the whole
substance of his life and yet remain the
same he feels no inclination to become
another person by no means regards that
is something great
only the lower nature's Kierkegaard says
forget themselves and become something
new a little bit later he says only the
lower nature's have the law for their
actions in someone else the premises for
their actions outside of themselves
so once you've attained to this point
where you're you can recognize and say
this is absolutely important this is
absolutely valuable I ought to orient
myself to it even though I'm not going
to be successful even though the world
is against me in this you don't abandon
that you don't abandon the value and you
don't abandon yourself in the process
again for Kierkegaard this is showing us
almost the very best of what human
beings are capable of the night of
infinite resignation does engage in
resignation and resignation is not
simply a moping around and saying oh I
can't hear of what I want it's not a
form of self-pity it is an acceptance of
how things are and a recognition that
they really could be otherwise but won't
be otherwise that they should be
otherwise that the value should be
realizable and yet won't be realizable
they resign themselves to what we can
call the impossibility within this
finite world of whatever it is that they
are valuing and Kierkegaard talks about
this in terms of here we go
he says fools and young people say
everything is possible for a human being
fools do because they don't know any
better that's what makes them fools
young people also say that because
they're rather hopeful they haven't had
enough
disappointments at least many young
people there are many young people who
have been so brutally disappointed or
brutalized and their horizons have
shortened incredibly but many of them
say everything is possible
Kierkegaard says that's a mistake
why on one side everything is possible
on another side it's not the case
he says spiritually speaking everything
is possible within the realm of the
infinite but in the finite world there
is much that is not possible we have for
example bodies that we don't entirely
control and we can do many things to
them you want to lose weight you can
diet and exercise and do all sorts of
other things as well which may or may
not work for you but you can't keep your
body from eventually breaking down
through aging maybe we'll even have
technology to reverse aging but sooner
or later something is going to catch up
with you and if you want that technology
it's very expensive so you'd better make
a lot of money but you might not be able
to make a lot of money in this finite
world there may be nobody who wants to
pay what you would like for your talents
so that you can realize this other good
you don't want to be spending all your
time hustling and making money you want
to attain this value over here but it's
not possible Kierkegaard uses other
examples of for example you know an
unhappy love unhappy in the sense that
it cannot be realized
two people are deeply in love with each
other deeply in love not just in the
sense of infatuation but appreciating
who the other person genuinely is and
wanting to live in a full lifetime
shared life relationship with that
person and yet it's simply not possible
given the finite circumstances that one
lives in we could take patriotism as an
example as well when patriotism is not
just jingoism and waving the flag but a
genuine law
of one's own country and the people who
people's many times who inhabit it that
can actually recognize the goodness of
other countries it can be an incredibly
potent value people will lay down their
lives for that sort of thing and rightly
so but it could be that your country
will still be conquered or that it'll be
run by some cabal of terrible people or
that the very patriotism that you
espouse will be used by those who just
want to engage in Wars or conflicts with
other people you don't control that so
resigning oneself to this this
impossibility is part of what the knight
is doing but notice what else he says
the knight makes the impossibility
possible by expressing it spiritually in
the realm that we can in fact have some
control over but he expresses it
spiritually by renouncing it he says the
desire that would lead him out into
actuality but as stranded on
impossibility is now turned inward this
is another aspect of us human being the
the common human nature that we share
that we can in fact turn inward we can
have an interior life even if everybody
else is against me and tells me that I'm
crazy for pursuing desiring loving this
this valuable thing I can still keep it
within myself and choose to protect it
protect that love protect that desire
from that hostile world but it means
that that's the only place that it
exists and in many cases there is a sort
of compensation for this Kierkegaard
points out he talks about the resilience
of resignation a capacity to continue on
to persevere he also talks about
becoming self-sufficient he says that
the one who has resigned in
not just finitely but infinitely is
sufficient to oneself the night does not
cancel his resignation it keeps his
loved just as young as it was in the
first moment this is about somebody
who's in love with somebody and cannot
have that relationship he never loses it
simply because he has made the movement
infinitely what the princess does cannot
disturb him only again only the lower
nature's have their law for their
actions in someone else the premises for
their actions outside themselves he says
in Infinite resignation we can find a
certain peace and rest he says every
person who wills it who is not to based
himself by self disdain can just
discipline himself to make this movement
this is a possibility for you and for me
for any of us who move beyond the
captivation of the world and the
esthetic into the ethical he says in
this we experience some pain but this
pain reconciles us to existence and he
says there's also a comfort in the pain
one can in fact do this this is a
genuine possibility this is not the best
thing for Kierkegaard but it's pretty
pretty good it's far better than most
other ways of living the last thing that
I want to point out I mentioned that the
night of infinite resignation exists in
relation to yet another night who
surpasses this one in certain ways both
of them to use this metaphor of the
ballet dancer leap into the infinite
they leap into something higher
something Universal and then they come
back down to the finite world and
Kierkegaard has this wonderful analogy
here where he he says that both of them
are making the movements of infinity all
right but the night of faith is doing it
somewhat different than the night of
finitude is doing so he says it is
supposed to be the most difficult feat
for a ballet dancer to leap into a
specific posture in such a way he never
wants strains for the posture but in the
very leap assumes the posture perhaps
there is no ballet dancer who can do it
but this night does it he says the
nights of infinity our ballet dancers
and have elevation they make the upward
movement and come down again and this
too is not an unhappy diversion and not
unlovely to see but here's the
difference he says every time they come
down they are unable to assume the
posture immediately they waver for a
moment and this wavering shows they are
aliens in the world it is more or less
conspicuous according to their skill but
even the most skillful of these nights
cannot hide this wavering which means
that like Kierkegaard said they are in
fact aliens or sojourners or whatever
term you prefer to say within this
finite world and yet they are in a
certain respect the greatest hope for
realizing genuine values within this
world each of them is a sort of world on
to him or herself which is why there is
a self-sufficiency there so this is a
very positive characterization of
infinite resignation
you